[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Merhaba Hoş geldiniz ben Sema size
anlatacak bazı şeylerim var Öncelikle
biraz kendimden
bahsedeceğim biraz bisikletli Yaşama
nasıl başladığımdan bahsedeceğim süslü
kadınlardan bahsedeceğim Ayrıca gri
yaşamım çiçek bahçesine nasıl dönüştü
ondan
bahsedeceğim süslü kadınlar bisiklet
turu ile ilgili ufak bir
tanıtım
önce 1973 Bandırma
doğumluyum 22 yıllık tarih öğretmeniyim
İzmir'de 38 yaşımda bisikleti öğrendim
ben bunun hikayesini anlatacağım süslü
kadınlar bisiklet turu 2013 yılında
öylesine başlayan planlanmamış bir
fikirdi ve sonra benim hiç tahmin
etmediğim yerlere doğru gitmeye başladı
4 yıldır yaptık bu yıl 24 Eylül'de ve
hiçbir kuruluşa bağlı değil süslü
kadınlar hiçbir derneğe herhangi bir
gruba bağlı olmadan yaptığımız gönüllü
kadınların yaptığı bir etkinlik Ama
öncelikle
ben biraz çocukluğumdan annemden
babamdan bahsetmek isterim Ben bir
öğretmen çocuğuyum annem babam köy
öğretmeniydi Ben 7 yaşıma kadar köyde
büyüdüm Annem gördüğünüz gibi her zaman
ağaçlara tırmanan çılgın bir kadındı
aydınlık bir kadındı Babam da öyle Hala
da öyleler Ben onlardan sanırım
aydınlığı ve gülümsemeyi aldım Bu benim
için çok özel bir durum Ben buradan
onlara teşekkür ediyorum
Eee ve benim hayatımda her zaman
hareketlilik vardı galiba hep bir
sahnede olmayı sever bir halim vardı
sanırım Benim yapım böyleydi bilmiyorum
ama insanlar la konuşmayı iletişimi her
zaman çok sevmiştim
Eee Peki ben bisiklete acaba hayatıma ne
zaman aldım söylemiştim baştan 38
yaşında aldım diye bu fotoğraf sizi
yanıltmasın E çünkü burada ben bisiklete
binmeyi bilmiyorum Sadece stüdyo
fotoğrafıyla kırmızı bir bisiklet
kaçırmışım ve babam maaşının yarısını
ona vermek zorunda kalmış onu anlatmış
mtı E ben sonra Bandırma'dan İzmir'e
okumak için gittim üniversiteyi
kazanmıştım ve Bandırma'dan sonra İzmir
benim için çok keyifliydi güzeldi ama
hiçbir zaman çok şaşırtıcı bir tane bile
bisikletli dikkatimi çekmemişti iki
tekerlekli bisiklete kesinlikle
binemiyorum fakat sonra öğretmen
olduktan sonra yakın arkadaşlarım
bisiklete binmeye başladılar ve E çok
ilginç bir şekilde onların değiş izledim
ben yanakları pembeleşme başladı daha az
Öfkeli olmaya başladılar ve bana dediler
ki Sema Bu tam senlik sen de öğren
hayatta öğrenmem
dedim İnat ettim yani Ama
sonra bana bir şekilde bunu sanırım
empoze ettiler ve ben de onları
kıskanmaya başladım dağlara gidiyorlar
keyifle geziyorlar ulaşım aracı
yapmışlar Ben de yazın Bandırma'ya
gittim ve babama dedim ki baba geç mi
kaldık yani ben bu ik erkli bisikleti
öğrenmek istiyorum Babam da o sıralar 68
yaşında e dedi ki kızım hiçbir şey için
geç değil hayatta her şey için mutlaka
bir fırsat vardır Hadi gel öğreteyim ben
sana babamla duygusal bir bağım oluştu
ve e babam 68 yaşında Eee bindi ve
bisiklet bisikletle gezmeye başladı
Hatta altından zor aldım bisikleti Eee
ve sonra arkamdan itmeye başladı Ben de
onunla Ben on itiyor zannediyorum bir
baktım gidiyorum kanatlanmış
gidiyorum Çok
heyecanlıydım ilk öğrenmeye başladığımda
sonra İzmir'e döndüm ve arkadaşlara
dedim ki arkadaşlar size bir sürprizim
var Çok da inatçı biriyim Ben aslında
ama bir
şekilde inadımı kırmayı başardım İyi ki
de başarmış sonra dediler ki Grup
sürüşünü öğrenmelisin böyle tek başına
gidemezsin sadece araçsız yerlerde
bisiklet olmuyor Türkiye'de her yerde
bisiklet yolu da yok Ben de Grup
sürüşünü öğrendim Ama kafama bir tüy
taktım beni görünce kaçın dedim Eee ve
böylece Benim adım uçuşan teker oldu
Lakabım Eee daha sonra dağlara çıkmak
istedi arkadaşlarım e ve beni de teşvik
ettiler Ben hayatımda hiç çadırda
kalmadım E tabii dünyaya biraz farklı
açılardan bakmak lazım bazen hayatınızı
değiştirmeniz eee size çok güzel şeyler
getiriyor güzellikler getiriyor Ama ben
çadırdan nefret ettim E çünkü
klostrofobim var ve çok korktum Ama
sonra yavaş yavaş alışmaya başladım
mutlu oldum Ben çadırda kalmaktan Eee
Çünkü ilk defa gerçekten doğanın parçası
olduğunu hissettim çadırda yere
yattığınızda çıtırtılar duymaya
başlıyorsunuz yürüyen böceklerin
çıtırtısı otlayan ineklerin çıtırtısı
Yani bu size bir süre sonra çok garip
bir huzur verm başlıyor Ben 39 yaşıma
kadar 40 yaşıma kadar bu duyguyu hiç
duymamışım hep otellerde beton
yığınlarının içinde kaldığımız için hiç
fark etmemişim Ben sevdim sonra ve daha
sonra
eee arkadaşlarla sohbet esnasında süslü
kadınlar bisiklet turu Fikri yavaş yavaş
ortaya çıkmaya başladı E bu fotoğrafta
gördüğünüz gibi kadınlar arkadan
ellerinde e bisikletleriyle gidiyorlar e
erkekler güçlü kaslarıyla Yokuşu gayet
rahat tırmanabilir Eee biraz turlar Bana
erkek Egemen gelmeye başladı Eee ve bazı
kadınlar da bana sormaya başladılar ya
Seman Sen 38 yaşında Eee nasıl öğrendin
heyecanlanmadan mı gerilmeden mi demeye
başladılar
Eee Evet gerildim Ben Hatta çoğu zaman
vazgeçmeye çalıştım Hatta hatırlıyorum
Bir gün turda bisikleti alıp Allah senin
belanı versin deyip aşağı attığımı
hatırlıyorum 5 dakika sonra gidip tekrar
bisiklete alıp binip devam ettim o
sırada arkadaşlarım benimle epey
uğraştılar sonra kadınların o söylemleri
işte ya Seman Nasıl yapsak Eee Biz de
binmek istiyoruz az bilen kadınları
teşvik etmem gerektiğini düşünü düşündüm
ve arkadaşlarla farkındalık eylemi
olarak süslü kadınlar bisiklet turu
fikrini beraber Aslında başlattık Eee
sonra bir farkındalık eylemi olduğuna
göre süslü ismini koyar
ve kadın özgürlük bisiklet temasını
işlersek kadınların buna ilgi
göstereceğini düşünüyordum ama yine de
ilk Tura herhalde 5 10 kişi gelir diye
bir fikrim
vardı sonra bir arkadaşım dedi ki Sema
böyle gelin hadi süslenin gelin
diyemezsin Hani bunu bir düzgün bir
çerçevede belirtmelisiniz
olmaması gerekiyor Kadının her alanda
kendini göstermesi gerekiyor bisiklette
de doğal bir şekilde günlük
kıyafetlerimizle bizim yollarda olmamız
gerektiğini kadınlara bir şekilde
anlatmak istedim ve inanamadım yani o
Konak meydanında zaten Zor Duruyorum
üstünde uçuşan bir tekerim e 2013
yılında Konak meydanına bir
gittim 200 tane kadın beni
bekliyordu hemen bisikleti ters çevirip
kaçmaya başladım arkadaşım zor tuttu
beni ve ondan sonra her şey değişmeye
başladı Benim
dünyamda 2014 yılında yaklaşık 500 kişi
2015'te 1000 kişi ve 2016 yılında e
Bunlar resmi rakamlar değil Bu arada ama
bildiğim kadarıyla 3000 4000
arası insan geldi ve inanılmaz bir andı
benim için Ben Hala inanamıyorum Bu
kadar insan nasıl geldi evlerinden
çıktılar E bana inandılar e bisiklete
inandılar özgürlüğe inandılar ve benimle
beraber geldiler Yollar şenlendi İzmir
şenlendi
Eee farklı şehirlerden insanlar bana
ulaşmaya başladılar Bu arada Normalde
İkinci yıl izin istediğimde bana hiçbir
yolu kapatmamış lardı geçen yıl Eee
şöyle dediler bana yetkililer
Hanım hangi yolları kapatalım hangi
yolları
istersiniz Ben
dedim ben de şöyle yaptım şöyle ana
caddeyi lütfen rica ediyorum dedim Bir
de dünya otomobilsiz kentler gününe denk
getiriyoruz Böylece gerçekten
otomobilsiz kentler gününe de vurgu
yapmış olduk Medya çok ilgilendi bizimle
Erkekler Erkekler ilk yı Dediler ki biz
vall dedim süslü kadınlar bisiklet
turuna gittik diyecekseniz Gelin buyurun
Ondan sonra Aslında 2 yıl istemedim
biraz dargınlıklar oldu Sonra baktım ki
zaten geliyorlar e gelin o zaman dedim
Bir de yolunu bulmuşlar o tandler o
ikili bisikletler var ya öne Papyon
takmış makam
şoförüyüm
almışlar böyle erkeklerimiz de artık
gelmeye başladı ya bu bir pozitif
ayrımcılık Tabii ki isteyen ama Biz
diyoruz ki arkada durun ve uygun
kıyafetle Gelin bu bizim için çok
önemliydi E tabii Ben Bir eğitimciyim
Öğretmenim öğrencilerime de aşılamaya
başladım ve birçok öğrencim benimle
beraber bisiklete binmeye başladılar Bu
benim için çok gurur verici bir şeydi
çok güzel şehir tanıtımı için de çok
güzel bir etkinlik oldu bu şehrimizi de
tanıtmış
olduk bu arada çok farklı insan grupları
geldi Ben kesinlikle
üst E bir söylem olması gerektiğini
düşünüyorum kadın bisiklet özgürlük
Gülümsemek bunları yaptığınızda her
kesimden insan sizinle geliyor çocuklar
aileler herkes gelebildi Eee ve farklı
Hayatlar yaşayan insanlar Aslında bazen
ortak bir payda olduğunda ve bu
gülümseyen bir payda olduğunda gerçekten
gelebilirler ve biz aslında bir arada
yaşayabiliriz ben bu turda bunu da
öğrenmiş oldum ve E çok da mutluydular
Eee İzmir'in kalbini Cumhuriyet
meydanında
attırmadan sonra mutlaka şarkı
söyleyerek bitiririm E bu benim duruşum
e ve burada da yine Bütün dünya buna
inansa bir inansa hayat bayram
olsa İnsanlar el ele tutuşsa birlik olsa
uzansak
sonsuza diyorum ve bu şekilde turu
bitiriyorum Eee Bu arada sunum bitmedi
Tabii ki çok
teşekkürler Bence bir etkinlik
yaptığınızda
Eee bunun sonucu ve nereye e denk
geldiği nerede oturduğu çok önemli yani
ben hep Kendime şunu sordum ben bunu
yapıyorum da Ne oldu şimdi yani yaptım
da ne oldu Eee gerçekten bazı faydaları
vardı Bunlar çok küçük görünen şeyler
mesela eee bir kadının ne BİM 60 yaşında
bir kadının E hiç bisiklete binmediğini
ve sonra öğrenerek devam ettiğini görmek
benim için o kadar rahatlatıcı bir şeydi
ki bütün yaşadığım strese değdi e mutlu
olduk gülümsedik Bir çocuk geldi Dünyası
değişti Bir Çocuk değişir dünya değişir
Bir Çocuk Gülümser Umarım dünya Gülümser
E hiç unutmayacak bugünü ve gülümsemekle
Anacak Bu arada farklı farklı kadınlar
bir araya geldiler toplandılar ve yeni
yeni gruplar oluşturmaya başladılar
bisiklet onlar için farkındalık oldu
bana verdikleri hediyelere kadar Ayfer
Ablam da bisikletçi oldu bu arada e beni
yolda görüp Aa benim de bisikletim var
deyip bana heyecanla anlatıyorlar Bu
benim için muhteşem bir şeydi Eee basın
çok fazla ilgilendi ve bu arada 2017 yıl
şey 2016 yılında 27 şehirde yapıldı bu
arada Bursa'dan da sümeyre arkadaşım
yaptı geçen yıl Bursa'da da süslü
kadınlar Bis bisiklet turu oldu ve bu
sene de Bursa'da Eee süslü kadınlar
bisiklet turu olacak 27 şehirde
yapılması Çok gurur vericiydi Konya
Kayseri Ordu Çorum Eee Bursa gibi birçok
şehirde bu turun yapılması çok önemliydi
yabancı basın gelmeye başladı farklı
farklı yerlerde Eee görüntülerimiz çıktı
Türkiye'den haberler gülümseyen haberler
gitmeye başladı e BBC World ana haber
bülteninde çıktık E daha sonra New York
Times röportaj yaptı ve New York
times'da yer aldı ve bir arkadaşım bana
dedi ki Sema ya sürekli dedi kötü
haberler geliyordu ülkemden sen dedi
ülkemden gülümseyen haber gönderdin ya
bize teşekkür ederim dedi E bu beni çok
etkiledi gerçekten ülkemin tanıtımı için
de çok önemli bir yere sahip olduğunu
düşünüyorum Peki bireysel olarak ben
bisikleti hayatıma aldım da ne oldu Eee
Bir kere ben hayatımda hep Eee Hani
araba kullanan toplu taşım da kullanan
bir insanım aklımın ucundan bile
geçmiyordu Ya ben bisiklette bir yerden
bir yere gideceğim mümkün değil Eee
şimdi ise arabay arabanın nerede
olduğunu unutuyorum otobüse binmek
aklımın ucundan bile geçmiyor birçok
yere e bisikletle gitmeye başladım ve
günlük kıyafetlerimle binilebilecek
öğrendim stresim azaldı Bu arada Eee ve
yanaklarım daha pembe olmaya başladı
daha sağlıklı görünmeye başladım eee
bisiklet turlarına gitmeyi öğrendim Bir
arabaya 10 tane bisikleti nasıl
sığdırırız onun yöntemlerini bulmaya
çalıştım Eee bisiklet turlarında Farklı
farklı insanlarla tanışıyorsunuz
bisiklet Hem bireysel bir şey senin
gücünle de ilgili bir şey ama aynı
zamanda bir araya gelip sosyal bir olgu
da olabiliyor Biz burada toplandığını
kimse kimseye ne iş yapıyorsun Nerede
müdürsün idareci misin gibi sorular
sormuyor herkesin tek bir ortak f e
paydası var işte ne güzel çıktık değil
mi ne güzel dağdı O işte benim
bisikletimin şurası bozuldu ya da
gülümseyerek birbirimizle e bisiklet
üzerine hayat üzerine sohbet ediyoruz
bisiklette statü yok Eee aynı zamanda
şehir afişlerinde yer almaya başladı
farkındalık oluşmaya başladı ve bazı
yabancı Bisikletçiler benim evimde
kalmaya başladı Ben Böylece dünyayla
tanışmaya başladım Eee Bu arada farklı
farklı etkinliklerde yer almaya başladık
arkadaşlarımız böyle gülümseyen eylemler
yapmaya devam etti ve Pınar bisikletli
Eee Parti yaptı çocuklar için Eee Bu
arada Eee yeni Bisikletçiler aramıza
katılmaya başladı Yasemin bana dedi ki
Sema Ben bisiklete binmeyi bilmiyorum
gel dedim gel beraber binelim Eee çok
farklı arkadaşlık paylaşımları yaşadık
Eee daha sonra E ben hiç gitmediğim
yerlere arabayla vın diye geçtiğimiz
yerlerde şöyle bir etrafıma bakınmak
hayatı yavaşlatıp durup şöyle bir
etrafıma bakmayı öğrendim bu arada Eee
Biz cep telefonu bağımlısı olduk bence
hastalandık Ben dahil Eee ama bisiklete
bindiğim an inanın aklımın ucundan bile
geçmiyor telefona bakmak sadece etrafıma
bakmayı Eee hissedebiliyorum Onun
haricinde bence bu bakımdan da bana çok
iyi geldi Bu arada ben bir astım
hastasıyım Eee ve bazen nefesim
gerçekten Eee düzenleyemiyorum Fakat ben
şu gördüğünüz fotoğraftaki dağa
tırmanmayı başardım
Ben burada bir şey öğrendim kendi içime
dönüp nefesini düzenle şimdi rahatla dur
ve bekle bunu hayatıma da uyarlamaya
başladım yani bisiklet benim okulum oldu
aslında nefesimi düzenleyen hayatımı
düzenleyen bir okulum oldu bu arada Eee
doğayla ilgili çok fazla şey eee yaşamış
oldum doğayı hissettim köylerden
geçerken teyzelerle sohbet ederek farklı
dünyalar tanıdım arabayla bunu
yapamıyorsunuz yani e yolun farkına
varamıyorsan arabayla bir şekilde bir
yere ulaşmaya çalışıyorsunuz sadece ama
bisiklette hep e etrafı fark etmeye
başlıyorsunuz Bu arada sosyal sorumluluk
projeleri de geldi peşinden ve ben
eylemlilik öğrenmeye başladım Critical
mesin ne olduğunu öğrendim Yolları
kapatıp arabalara doğru arabadan in
bisiklete bin diye bağırıp kaçtığımız e
söyleyebilirim size bazen kızıyorlar
bazen de a Bravo deyip devam ediyorlar
Eee Umarım arabadan inip bisiklete
binecekler Eee eylemlilik demiştim yine
beyazlı Yerde yatan benim arkadaşımıza
Eee otobüs çarptı İzmir'de Eee onun
eylemini yapıyoruz ve epey de etkili
oldu bu eylemden sonra belediye Eee
otobüs şoförlerine eğitim vermeye
başladı bisikletliler le ilgili eğitim
verdi Bu çok güzel bir şeydi çok
olursanız ve örgütlü olursanız bir
şekilde sizi görüyorlar tanıyorlar
biliyorlar
Eee
Ayrıca babamla olan Eee iletişimimi
ailemle ablam İlkay ve babam Orhan beyle
e ve annem seferiye Hanım'la olan
iletişimim bambaşka bir boyuta ulaştı
Eee onlar da heyecan duymaya başladılar
bir belgesel çekimim var Şu sıralar
Babam da oynadı onda Eee ve ödüller
gelmeye başladı bu arada e bir şekilde
gelin damat gördüğümde hemen gidip
bisikleti önlerine koyuyorum Çünkü
yengesi halası amcası Herkes bu
fotoğrafa bakıyor ya ha bisiklet
desinler galiba bisiklet misyoneri gibi
bir şey oldum ben herkesin eline
tutuşturup bir fotoğraf çektiriyorum ya
sonuçta bisiklet aslında bana şunu
öğretti bir şekilde gidiyoruz Zaten ve
Bir şekilde hayat zaten yeterince gri O
yüzden de biraz durup bakınıp
güzellikleri görmek lazım diye
düşünüyorum ben ve Eee biraz hayatı
yavaşlatıp seçtiğin yolu bazen düşünüp
Ya ben niye bu yoldayım acaba başka bir
yol daha var mı diye düşünmek lazım
Çünkü ben öylesine bir hayat Yaşarken
bir hocanım Ken kendime farklı bir yaşam
tarzı seçmeye karar verdim ve iyi ki de
öyle yapmışım diyorum bana bazı insanlar
şöyle söylüyorlar
Eee işte terör olaylarının ortasında Sen
giyindin süslendim işte bisikletini
süsledin gittin utanmıyor musun diyenler
var Bana iyi de e birilerinin de barışı
hatırlatması gerekmiyor mu yani her şey
mi ya bence yapabilecek ufacık bir
şeyimiz var insanlara bunu hatırlatmamız
gerekmiyor mu Ben de Barış'ı hatırlatmak
istiyorum en büyük amaçlarım biri de bu
Barış yolunuz olsun
teşekkürler